you know what I am I am hungry as hell
I'm gonna give y'all a heads up if you
smell anything remotely like bacon and
cheese you better run the hell up out my
way I will bite you like a hungry
cheetah into the fat ass of an antelope
is it back I did I was missing something
what up hey Uncle speeding it's like a
fire on the snapchat it snows gonna be
for a workout love it you our fugitive
man look David don't hurt himself he's
on the ground right now passed out on
this time I've been mocking up this
whole area there's some nice Hall down
it was a mystery I would say colors
jacket Oh what is going on Fitness fam
this is the third room I just spit bill
with it this is the third week that I'm
into this whole fitness thing and let me
tell you something I am hungry as hell
now with this new fitness lifestyle and
new diet you all know that we were good
we're gonna be hungry let's shoot now
the problem with being a fat guy and
eating the way I used to my whole life I
don't really think I know what the word
hungry means so what I'm trying to tell
you guys is that I'm not sure if the
hungry that I am is me really being
hungry I am what you call fat man hungry
meaning there's food in my stomach just
not the food that I mom could we all
know chicken breast and steamed
vegetables does not replace a
filet-o-fish with a small fry some
chicken nuggets a double cheeseburger
with a McChicken on the side and just
for dessert a little bit of McFlurry
with the Raisman
oatmeal cookie right inside of it on top
of that with the holiday pie
MacDonnell's do you not want to sponsor
me why what about so I'm eating but my
cravings aren't being met so I'm you
know I'm left feeling very unsatisfied
it's like when you cut yourself the porn
and then your parents walk in and you
about that you know yeah I'm saying
that's not it I don't do that kind of
stuff I'll just hoping you were late huh
oh my god so if you guys want another
diet plan that I am on it was set up by
my friend Mikey now if you guys don't
know who mikey is you guys could check
him out on instagram he's a really good
friend of mine and he is a fitness
inspiration
let me show you a transformation pic of
him real quickly this right here
ah damn he was fat s but you know it's a
funny story about the first time I met
Mikey [ __ ] mmm when Bart first
introduced who Mikey was to me he was
showing me how much he had transformed
from his previous body and when I saw it
I was pretty amazed
so the moment Mikey looks at my ass he
looks at me and says hey Davey you could
do it too if you want to and then I was
like did you just call me fat the [ __ ]
now I know what a lot of you guys are
thinking out there this is a first world
problem oh my god he has food in his
stomach oh man and I know this might
seem like a bit of an exaggeration but
for those of you out there who have
never really struggled with their weight
if you haven't realized carbs and sugars
are almost like an addiction see over
years and years of constantly getting
accustomed to a diet that was high in
carbohydrates that's what we fiend for
especially for energy so basically all
the foods that I was very chemically
dependent on I cut out so that includes
anything with caffeine so you could
imagine how hard it was to do that
cold turkey initially what happened to
me once I took out all the carbs and the
caffeine out my diet like I said I had
huge migraines I was incredibly listless
and really really tired and of course
consequently from all this [ __ ] I
actually developed a syndrome called
Babs big-ass [ __ ] syndrome those first
three days if you were in my way I was
going to murder you I huh and it even
got to a point where even the most
ridiculous [ __ ] starting to piss me off
this bird yesterday was outside my
window chirping I swear that
[ __ ] was saying chi-ching
chi-ching chi-ching the this [ __ ] is
called me a chick but the racist ass
bird here's the thing I know myself very
well so I know that a lot of you out
there are thinking why don't you just
cheat a little bit here and there and
it'll help with the cravings listen I'm
not that type of guy you can't give me
like a bite of a double cheeseburger and
i'ma stop right there it's gonna be
carnage it's like being a crackhead
you can't tell a crackhead okay buddy
here's a little crack rock yeah but
don't smoke the rest yeah i'ma leave it
in your hands that's smart yeah you see
what I'm saying it doesn't make any
sense it's like have you ever seen a
lion just eat half a zebra that [ __ ]
never happens
what's the line gonna be like ya [ __ ]
imma save the rest for later
mmm I hurry no this is gonna be a long
week and I've already been doing this
for two weeks and it gets harder and
harder
you know I first won
the salad it wasn't so bad a lot of
people were telling me to vary the type
of leave me said I was having whether it
was gonna be salmon I don't know tilapia
cod pork loin it doesn't [ __ ] matter
because it's not what I want but I'm
here it's the third week or the
beginning of the third week and I'm
still doing this so I just want to let
you guys know that it is very possible
you know don't give up put your [ __ ] out
there and uh let's get it
so Fitness fam always remember life is
what you make it but it's up to you to
take what you deserve
see y'all next time hey what is going on
YouTube hello but yes that is the
completion of week two which means I'm
starting week three of funny fat Finn
and yes it has been getting more and
more difficult to go to the gym just
because a lot of you told me that I will
stop being sore at the first week you
[ __ ] liars honestly if you're not
sore is some part of your body and tired
then you're just not working out hard
enough baby that's why I said it so once
again if you guys want to know where I
work out at barbell brigades in Monterey
Park yes holla holla holla they are the
reason why I'm even going to the gym
still to this day because of their
positive environment and just before
this video and so I can clarify what I
mean by cutting out carbs is that I'm
only eating complex carbs right now and
that's only in the morning so for those
of you guys have questions about that I
just wanted to answer it real quick but
yes family if you guys notice there are
videos to the left and to the right
which are previous vlogs and the
previous funny fat fit so if you aren't
going on this journey with me remember
tweet me hashtag at FFF or funny fat fit
and I will check out your progress
videos and give you guys words of
encouragement there haven't been a lot
of you living doing these videos I do
want you to do it because it will keep
you accountable don't be afraid but if
you're not going to do the videos just
do it with me and tweet me everyday just
because I want to see your progress and
even if I don't respond back I am
reading it and you know because I need
to you guys helping me out too so
remember fitness fan of life is what you
make it but it's up to you to take what
you deserve
let's go for broke BAM I said this time
sitting on this bench too long why you
playing with these basic fake men
and go complaining when it all goes
wrong if you over your eyes gigas is a
tray
okay all you need